Today,
I'm going to talk about the transition
from part one to part two of the,
uh, Jihadi, um,
our transition not serve and this
is a transition, uh, remember,
uh, that he didn't know for sure
that he wasn't a right a second part.
Of course when he wrote the second card,
he knew for sure that he had
written part one and it is a, uh,
a transition for us, uh, and
also a transition in his life,
uh,
but not one that was envisioned
when part one was being conceived.
I underline that fact.
I have said several times because the
illusion is created that it is one book by
the fact that it is all bound together.
You will see today, uh, that uh,
are quite different as books because
we will be seeing the title pages, uh,
of them.
Um,
I would begin by reviewing what
I call the grand themes of,
uh, criticism, uh,
regarding part one before
moving on to part two.
Now the first of those grant themes,
number one is ambiguity and perspectivism.
This is a review session, uh, as it were,
uh, Leo Spitzer, whom you will be meeting
in a week or so when you read his, uh,
uh, very fine piece in the case book
called linguistic perspective is in Minto.
Quixote, uh, says the
following. Uh, I want to do,
you're going to talk about his
conclusions. We will talk more about,
uh, how he comes to those conclusions
after you have read, uh, his, his piece.
But I need to go over his conclusions.
Uh,
he says this means that in our novel
mean Nikki Haughty things are represented
not fort why they are in themselves,
but only as things spoken
about or thought about.
And this involves breaking the narrative
presentation into two points of view.
There can be no certainty about
the own broken reality of events.
The only unquestionable truth on which
the reader may depend is the will of the
artist who chose to break
up a multivariant reality
into different perspectives.
In other words,
per perspective is him suggests an
archimedean principle outside the plot.
And the Archimedes must
be Servantez himself,
meaning the archimedean principle,
the focus,
the center of the Fulcrum is
Cervantes himself who has created this
perspectives.
He adds a Spitzer outs and we may see in
Cervantes is two fold treatment of the
problem of nicknames, which has
studies in great detail in his article.
Another example of his baroque attitude,
we will be talking about the Baroque,
uh, extensively in the next few lectures.
He's baroque attitude. What is true,
what is a dream?
This is one of the topics of the Baroque.
This time continuous Spitzer toward
language is not human language.
Also,
Vanita Vanitas,
Vanny tattoo vanity of vanities
is quoting of course a scripture
that's the end of Spitzer.
And we saw that CD Echo Morang
Aroyo who's a name you have heard,
uh, before, uh, what,
what he said about irony,
I'm repeating a quote that you heard
in a previous lecture. He says,
I agree with spitzers
definition of servant Ian
perspectivism and now he quotes
Spitzer, who says, in terms of morals,
Cervantes is in no way a perspective is,
does the end of the spitter quote
within the Merona Royer quote in a note,
more on a Rodeo continues.
He has,
perhaps we ought to point out here,
this is CDR core Bordonaro you
perhaps we are to point out here that
perspectivism is inherent
in two Christian thought.
Uh,
prospective ism is in the sense of a form
of modesty that recognizes the limits
of all judgment and human knowledge
is indeed a Christian humility and
intelligence, uh, in the strictest sense,
the capacity to perceive the
limit of our own creations.
And then he uses the Greek word for irony,
irony.
So perspectivism this partial view
that creates, is irony and so forth.
Moron earlier underlines is
a very Christian perspective.
I would add that the,
the self assurance of the
renaissance, uh, is being eroded,
uh, on the ordered cosmos
of the Middle Ages, uh,
has long disappeared.
Uh,
now that is the, the first of
the grand themes, uh, ambiguity,
perspectivism and so forth.
The second of the grand themes is that
the self can impose its will on reality,
but only to a certain extent.
I'm the self is defined.
That self is defined by the agonistic
struggle to do so to input between
postage. Well, on reality, uh,
we, uh, uh,
Captain Ahab in Melville's,
Moby Dick is the most obvious modern
example in fiction. And also of course,
an air of donkey hope. The Melville
was a great reader of Cervantes.
Uh, remember in this context of
imposing our will on reality.
Uh, what I said about, uh,
how we invent our beloveds when
in love that is part of this, uh,
of this willful imposition, uh,
of ourselves on, on reality.
Um,
now why is doubt such an integral part
of what we could call the aesthetics of
the, uh, how can doubt
be a positive value?
The book gives of substance,
uh,
to the sense of doubt brought about
by the scientific discoveries and
philosophical ideas of the period.
It enacts doubts,
the Quixote. It dramatizes
it. Dramatizes it is,
it is the, a modern
condition. Remember what I,
what I mentioned about, uh,
uh, a coper, Nicole's Galileo,
the fact that the world of mankind is
no longer at the center of the world.
The earth is no longer at the center
of the universe. And this is a,
has brought about this,
uh, sense of, of doubt.
There is doubt. Uh, continuing
with this second grand theme,
uh, there is doubt about
the voracity of texts,
the capacity of text to convey the truth,
including,
and most prominently the Bible.
Oh,
the Bible as interpreted
by the Catholic Church, uh,
such a doubt was the only prevalent
among Protestant thinkers,
but also among Catholic Catholic
ones like Erasmus of Rotterdam.
Erasmus is one of the, this
great renaissance figures
that I have, uh, mentioned,
uh, as being important,
uh, for, uh, sort of,
and this is a time the humanists,
Erasmus was one.
We're philologists.
The philologists means lover of language,
Phyllo Logos,
lover of language,
students of language,
particularly classical
languages like Latin,
Greek and Hebrew. Chairs
for the study, uh,
of these languages were created in Spain,
uh,
at the University of Alcoa,
for instance,
that pound where Cervantes happens
to have been born by the way,
uh,
humanists like Erasmus wanted to read
a scripture in the original Hebrew and
Greek, Hebrew, Old Testament Greek,
the new testament and challenge
saying your ohms official Latin Bible.
They wanted to do their own
translations of the Bible.
The church didn't like this at all.
And the Erasmian in Spain were persecuted.
Yeah.
But there is an underlying, uh, Erasmian,
uh, subtext in most of the, this,
the humanists like Erasmus wanted to say,
uh,
wanting to say the reading of this,
word in St Jerome's a Latin
version of the Bible is wrong.
It should be this.
And of course,
changing that word changes
the meaning of the text.
So there was doubt about the sacred texts,
which builds over into doubt about
texts in general and about language.
And we certainly have a echoes of
this throughout surrenders his work.
There is also continuing with
the second grand theme of doubt,
ontological doubt,
doubt about who one is,
which is an encouragement
to self creation,
to self fashioning to self invention as
Steven Greenburg Greenblatt calls it in
his book,
Renaissance Self Fashioning in Quixote.
There are many characters we
have seen who invent themselves,
not just on Quixote.
Uh,
he nest [inaudible] Marcella [inaudible]
springs is becoming Kona and so forth.
Doubt leads to pondering.
Pondering comes from
bundles in Latin way too.
So pondering is to way uh,
uh,
to weigh the different possibilities.
There are differences,
different alternatives to,
to being to action.
Self doubt is the
precondition to inventiveness,
to the play of the imagination.
It is the gateway to freedom,
which is one of the main themes of
the guilty as I have been pointing out
throughout
doubt,
doubt leads to vicarious lives,
live through literature,
as in the cases of Don Quixote
and Marcella for instance,
and many others that you will
meet in part to this is again,
I underlined the freedom
of the imagination.
Why do we want to become
others in the age of myths?
We want it to be gods in the modern age.
We want to be heroes like donkey hot.
They want it to be one of the two Valerie
heroes and like people today want to
be James Bond or uh,
such a modern, uh, hero,
a dissatisfaction with the world,
the world that is unstable leads to a
desire to make it other and to make one's
self other.
And this is very much the core of the
whole day from the very beginning.
Now the third of the ground themes
that I'm reviewing as we conclude,
part one reading Nikki hotter is a book
about reading and it protagonist is
first and foremost a reader.
But there are many readers in the
book like Marcella Ag Resource, Tomo,
[inaudible],
and even the poor trooper who has trouble
reading the order of arrest as we saw
in that hilarious scene.
The Quixote,
the that you thought the encourages the
reader to look for stories not told or
calling directly by means of other
stories or embedded in other stories.
It is a book,
a hotel that is a lesson in reading
and interpreting in the broad sense.
There are so many scenes in
which challenge a deputation was,
are challenged or interpretations
by various characters clash.
The pleasure of reading
involves the discovery,
the teasing out of this subtextual
stories as we saw when we talked about
Cardenio story, uh, unwise. We,
so when we talked about
Princess Mikami corners story,
this is also a lesson for life
that one can learn in the hotel.
The fourth of the,
uh,
grand themes is that
characters are relational,
not static that they develop
in relation to each other
and given to us today.
This was an innovation in the Quixote
and innovation developed from the
picaresque where there is
character development in
fiction for the first time in
the Selestica. There is a, there
is some of that already 1499,
but this begins to develop
with the picker risk.
Last year, 1554, the Guzman and so forth.
Characters influence each other.
The mutual influence and transformation
take place by virtue of the dialogue
which posits that the self is
relational and dependent on the others.
This is evident in one of the truly
grand themes about the hotel started by
Salbaba.
They must Ariaga,
which is the theme of the
quick Saudization of sensual
and the sanctification of
donkey. Haughty meaning that
donkey, that a sancocho becomes a,
is influenced by his master,
and that Don Quixote is influenced
by his squire. The most,
the most obvious modern
example of this, uh, for me,
uh, is a, uh, a book and a,
uh, on a film that, uh,
called the kiss of the
Spiderwoman by Manuel [inaudible],
the Argentine writer,
uh, where, uh, there is,
uh, uh, there are two
fellows, Eh, uh, in jail,
in Argentina want a political activist.
And the other homosexual. And,
and the whole story is, is,
is how the homosexual, uh,
transforms the political activists by
telling him the stories of movies. And,
uh, it's a very moving a film
with a very quick Celtic, uh,
uh, uh, uh, structured to it,
but at least two characters talking
and so forth. Now don't fit it.
Nando's transformation as
well as that of Dorothea.
Is it a, is a prime example of
this evolution of characters.
Uh,
in addition,
we have seen the characters can invent
themselves identities and have adventures
in their new roles and within those
new fictions. As in the case of, uh,
of Princess Mikko be corner, we will
meet others who do the same in part to
the fifth of the grand
themes of criticism.
And this is mostly my own grand theme
about the Quixote is improvisation.
I have talked several times about
improvisation in the Quixote.
My Random House gives
two meanings to four, uh,
four to improvise,
one to prepare or provide
offhand or hastily extemporize
to compose,
but actually for meanings to compose
verse music on the spur of the moment.
Three to recite thing extemporaneously
and four to compose other or execute
anything extemporaneously.
The dictionary of the Spanish
Academy says, personally,
I said it on our costs are
prone [inaudible] studio
senior [inaudible] Alguna to
make or do something.
Suddenly we thought study or preparation.
Improvisation has something
to do with blurry.
Equally a concept that was very popular
during the heyday of structuralism.
And that means according to my
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible],
the first one probably swap [inaudible]
fancy fee to install something to
provide or arrange for something.
I'm a tourist league and ingeniously to
fix or repair something more or less in
a professional way to fix something up
too fancy foil to falsify it or pass it
off for something else to improvise
has on the one hand a positive side,
it is a boast of skill to be able to
do something without a model or plan,
but it also has a negative side because
the product of improvisation is usually
shorty imperfect,
fragile, and provisional.
We have seen that there is a great deal
of implicit improvisation in part one of
the Quixote somatically.
I said where a meaning that there are
things and actions had described which are
improvised.
I gave one pal Omegas in as an example
of this because it is made up of
Patchwork, uh, carried out
over time, haphazardly.
But I also pointed our features of the
novel itself that seemed to be trade
their construction.
They're notorious 17 oversights such
as the disappearance of Santos Donkey,
but there are many others.
For instance,
I don't know if you noticed that it said
Advantis pulls out of his out of his
hat at the end that the
innkeeper but one polemic,
uh,
was a trooper of the holy brotherhood.
Something that goes on mentioned
during the earlier episode.
In the end when quantile Omeka puts
out a candle to prevent a trooper from
finding out what is going
on in his establishment,
how come if he was a trooper himself,
I these lapses on the part of Cervantes
or part of the aesthetics of the book,
I would like to think that it is part of
the aesthetics of the book and that the
air of improvisation is very much in line
with the books in formal tone with the
fact that its origin is presumably a
found manuscript whose discovery is
episodic and who's redaction,
uh,
seems to be concomitant with
the action and the reading.
Most notoriously,
the prologue,
the [inaudible] dramatizes the process
of improvisation because it tells how it
is being laboriously written.
The prologue sets the tone for
the book and it's defined and,
and it is also if defining
epilogue as I said earlier, it is,
I know to improvisation to an
imperfection qualities too,
which the author resigns himself.
Remember that many and the speed dial
in the piece that you read, attributes,
improvisation, do the Spanish
character, he says this was resignation.
He's a Spaniard.
GMC was a Spaniard himself and
Isi Riley British has been,
is to love Spain. Uh, uh,
admiringly compares to the improvisation
in the Quixote to fighting and to
Flamenco dancing,
which are activities in which
improvisation is the order of the day.
I believe that it is a
theoretical statement on the
part of their Vantis which
he proposes again in chapter
five of the 1615 Quixote.
The second part when
he has the translator,
apologize and you will get to the
chapter for transcribing a text in which
central does not sound like
himself sounds to learn it.
This is a text that on dos itself
that is as, as it is being read,
it is also a critique of my niece,
me, my missus of representation.
It is an improvisation made from what
there is and at the translator and
transcriber pass on resigned.
Oh, it's imperfections.
All of this is connected to the themes
that I mentioned before about doubt,
self doubt and linguistic uncertainty.
How can my poor self create something
perfect and enduring in language given
what I have said about doubt,
self doubt on the instability of
language and conceived by the humanists,
uh, the whole, the whole thing. Uh,
it also opens the question of
temporality about this text that says,
well,
this doesn't sound like San job.
I transcribe it because it is my
duty to do so on so forth. Uh, uh,
in what moment or at what moment does
the Texas exist in relation to the
originals in which it is based?
Yeah.
Uh,
one solution,
perhaps the only solution is to say that
the texts exists only at the moment of
reading of each reading.
And that is a very modern,
uh,
current conception of textuality
that is already present in Cervantes.
So these are the grand themes that I
wanted to review with you about part one.
And now we move to part two 16,
15, 10 years. The whole
decade has elapsed.
Cervantes was an instant
success with Don Quixote.
Uh, and he moved to Madrid in 16, 16.
Publishers become interested in his
work and he brings out the novella a him
Pladis exemplary stories that you have
in 1613 on Ochoco Manias [inaudible]
eight place and eight interludes in 60 16,
15 the same year that the
second Quixote appears.
And I have a page here that you have read,
but I want to read again,
uh, from Darren's book set Avantis. Uh,
and from the biogas little biographical
chapter at the beginning that I
reproduced in my case
book so that we have, uh,
a synoptic view in 1606 durangos
the court settled again in Madrid.
And you have been following an Elliot.
The migrations of the Spanish court said
Vantis and his family moved with it.
Cervantes wanted to be in
touch with other writers.
I was looking for new publishers,
the women in his household,
busy with fashion and designing and
sewing. We're looking for customers.
Miguel's last year in Madrid,
we're relatively serene.
He overcame through patience and wisdom,
all these adversities that
neglect the famous writers.
And so just the Vega who seldom had a
good word for his works and the sadness of
family crisis.
His daughters married but soon became uh,
his daughter married but soon became
the mistress of a wealthy middle age
businessman.
When Cervantes intervened in the
interest of preventing scandal,
she became a stranger.
Never again visited him.
Cervantes immersed himself in his work.
It was harvest season
for him late in life,
yet in full command of his talent, he
produced in books, work session at Sam.
He's extemporary Nawbo 16, 13, the second
part of Funky Hotel 1615. And finally,
Perseus answer, he's wound. That's the his
though and novel, which is imagination.
Uh, and his love for adventure
found almost limitless in scope.
And he hides a quoting, uh,
unhealed del Rio and he'll del Rio,
the Great Hispanics who was a professor
at Columbia University for many years
and who in the forties, published a
great history of Spanish literature.
Wrangles objectively serve
life was not a success story.
He will sell them in full control.
He was too poor for many years.
He lacked public recognition.
Yet as an hill del Rio points out,
and here he goes on in the real.
There is no reason to lament.
Cervantes is misfortunes nor the
mediocrity of his daily life.
He could those through an experience
which is seldom obtain when the writer is
successful and wealthy,
no observe and feel the beat of
Spanish life and its greatness.
And it's poverty and it's heroic fantasy.
And in,
in the sad reality of
an imminent decadence,
he was to leave in his books the most
faithful image of this life reflected in
multiple perspectives with bittersweet
irony and penetrating humor.
So the, uh, uh, uh,
this moment of where the beginning
of the decline of the Spanish empire,
uh, begins. And so, uh, to also, uh,
have a very clear vision of this moment.
Uh,
I want to read a text that I presumably
you have a also read from imperial
Spain. Uh, Elliott's a marvelous book,
which I do do hope that
you, that you read. Uh, um,
and he goes as follows.
In page.
This is three 19 three 20 of
your penguin classics edition.
He has been talking
about, um, uh, how, uh,
um, the writers could find sponsors
for their work and so forth.
At the same time,
the moral and emotional involvement of
the intellectuals in the tragic fate of
their native land seems to have
provided an additional stimulus,
giving an extra degree of intensity to
their imagination and diverting it into
rewarding creative channels.
Ironically,
a moment of crisis can
create a great literature.
This was especially true
of Cervantes says Elliott,
who's life from 1547 to 1616 spans the
two ages of imperial triumph and imperial
retreat.
This is the important sentence spans
the two ages of imperial triumph and
imperial retreat.
The grace,
the crisis of the late 16th century cuts
through the life of Servantez as it got
through the life of Spain separating
the days of heroism from the days of
[inaudible]. This is a word that we will
be visiting again during the semester.
Okay.
They'll be on deceived,
somehow said Van.
There's magically held the balance
between optimism and pessimism.
Enthusiasm.
I'm irony,
but it illustrates what was to be the
most striking characteristic of 17th
century literary and artistic production.
That deep cleavage between the two
worlds of the spirit and the flesh,
which coexist and yet
our forever separate.
This constant dualism between
the spirit and the flesh.
The dream and the reality belonged
very much to 17th century European
civilization as a whole,
but it seems to have attained an
intensity in Spain that it rarely achieved
elsewhere.
It is apparent in the writings
of Calderon de la Barca,
whose name I have mentioned before and
the portraits of guest who's work we have
seen and continue to see,
and it prompted the bitter
satires of Canedo Francisco.
They came in through one of
the great writers of this,
of this vanish.
Yeah,
17th century.
He's quoting here,
so give me a little bit, are many
things here that seemed to exist on,
have there been and yet they are nothing
more than a name and an appearance.
[inaudible] road at the end of his life
was the reality of Spanish experience to
be found in the heroic imperialism of
Charles the fifth or in the humiliating
passivism of Phillip,
the third in the world of Don Quixote or
the world of central Panzer confused at
once by its own past and its own present.
The [inaudible] still of Philip,
the third,
the land of Arabic priestess
sought desperately for an answer.
I'd be curious.
Does you will meet in the
first chapters of a part two
from RBT or which was a, uh,
an opinion [inaudible] where,
uh,
um,
people who offered advice to the
government on matters of the economy on
military matters.
Some of the advice was really outlandish.
Uh, if he saw the people who
developed into today's economists,
the ones who have brought us to the
present crisis is what I always think of
when I think of the beauty status.
Uh, you will be meeting them,
as I said at the beginning of part two
when the characters discuss them and
discuss some of these advice given to the,
and donkey Horta himself.
Act as an arbitrary start by
giving some advice on how to, uh,
take care of the threat of the Turks,
uh,
coming down again after
the defeat in Lepanto.
So,
uh,
we are not responsible for answering
the question of what happened in Spain.
Why was it different?
Uh,
but we are responsible for seeing the
effects of this crisis as reflected in a
Saran thesis work. And I
wanted to do, to have a clear,
uh, uh, view of this, uh, uh, two ages of,
uh, of empire, uh, uh, one,
one of triumph and one of of defeat.
Um,
now the second part,
uh,
let us look at the, uh, uh,
various titles. Uh, the title,
that page of that we saw
of the 16 or five Quixote,
the title page of the 1615 Quixote
and the title page of the [inaudible],
he, he's known by his second
last name or some people are,
and you have to remember his name.
You will see it complete now on the,
on on the screen, a, yeah, a Ne the,
uh,
because
the two things that have happened to
Cervantes since the publication of 605,
the most important things is to the
success of the Quixote. And in 16,
14,
the appearance of an Apocryphal
Quixote published by [inaudible].
Now this is the,
uh,
title page of the 16 or five jihad.
The one we had just finished part
one. And this is as is, no. Okay.
[inaudible] remember we went over each
one of those words in one of my first
classes.
Okay.
Now we go to the title
page of the 1615 Quixote.
Uh,
and you say Segunda Party dealing
Henny Kava Yanno key hotel,
a mantra. There has been a major
change. He's no longer an e.
Dot. Logo. Now he's a Caballero
boredom.
Miguel Lesser Vantis Saavedra I will
tore the La Primera party by Miguel de
[inaudible].
Author of the first part is being
underlying because [inaudible] in 16,
14,
there had appeared and apocryphal Quixote.
Okay.
Say Wound
[inaudible] [inaudible] the third
Sally. It will be the third. Sally,
uh, years. La, la, la I. Dot. E
E Lakita the fifth part,
because he goes after,
normally the first part is divided in
four. So this is the fifth part. Uh,
and so on, so forth, uh,
by, uh, loan software.
[inaudible] see, yes. Uh,
born in the, uh, in the
village of total. The sea. Yes.
Cause he just, he's a very famous,
uh, little town nearby. A lead.
Why?
Does anyone remember why no one remembers
why that treatise of after the seed.
Yes. You're all very learned
Yalies the treaties d software,
the seizures whereby the pope,
uh,
in 1494 divided up to new world
between Portugal and Spain.
Uh, Francois Premiere,
Francis the first of France,
later complaining in the 16th century,
she says they wanted to see Adam's will
where Adam had bequeathed all of this
world to the Spanish,
but so toward the seizure.
So you remember to turn
the suggestion now. Uh,
so he took over a year though.
Not only I need, I'll go.
Is it because of Cervantes
felt that his deeds,
quote unquote in the first part,
elevated him tonight?
Uh,
some believe that the change was made at
the printers and not bite Advantis uh,
in part to, uh, distinguish
this book from our Jeunesse,
which still call it either,
so you call it [inaudible] night to
distinguish it from the Apocrypha.
Also,
some have said that the printers felt,
you see the hotels you have learned
was immediately translated into several
languages, English, French and so forth.
And the printers felt that Caballero
night was easier to translate into other
languages then either Evalgo editors
tend to make such changes in the interest
of profits. But, uh, we,
we don't know exactly,
but the fact is that the cha,
the title has been, uh, changed.
Uh, and this is a good way of remembering
that this is a different book.
Uh,
now the second part was,
uh,
finished in a hurry.
I said,
one is due in large measure to
the publication of the 1614 hour.
You're neither a spurious.
Second part.
Second parts had appeared
of [inaudible] of Guzman,
uh, of the cell is Tina,
not to mention, uh,
those of romances of chivalrous as we
saw in the episode of the scrutiny of the
books, there were whole cycles.
Second, third, fourth sparts.
Uh,
why
William Hendricks,
Hendricks has recently finished a
doctoral dissertation about sequence,
uh,
and demonstrated that sequels dominated
the 16th century in Spain when the most,
uh,
were among the most popular of books and
a whole poetics of the sequel emerged
that the same thing to write a book from
scratch than to write a book that is
the continuation of a previous book.
Why was this,
why did this happen?
Well,
it happened because with
the advent of printing,
it was, uh, uh, uh, uh,
easier to produce these books and to
disseminate them and to make a profit from
them. So second parts,
uh, proliferate it. So,
uh,
in writing a second part of the Quixote
Cervantes is following this trend.
Most recently, the second part of it was
Mondale Farace, which had been published,
uh, right before the first part of
the, uh, of the [inaudible], uh,
now in why was he, uh, uh, so, uh,
upset or the appearance of the,
uh,
of a Neda [inaudible] because these novels
were big and these characters who are
becoming commodities
over which people would quarrel.
Remember that we're talking about authors,
as I have mentioned in earlier classes,
who are the first professional offers
we're trying to make a living from,
uh,
the writing.
So the Quixote was a
commodity for a set of Lantis,
uh,
particularly because this was not a
character derived from classical mythology
to which anyone had a right or from one
of those cycles of jewellery romances
which had been used and reuses
the character that he invented.
So he felt it was his own.
Of course,
the character would become a literary
myth under then taken up by others.
But, uh, at this juncture is around,
this was very jealously guarding
his, uh, his creation. He is,
he is, uh, very much aware of the,
of the value of his
invention because of his too.
He brought in fame and also
because he brought him a profit.
And in fact you will get to a,
a,
an episode in part to that
is a brilliant satire of uh,
the uh, relationship between
money and literary creation.
Something that we take for granted.
Now I need is the episode where Gnocchi
hope smashes a puppet show that was
brought by none other, that he missed
the pass them onto these guys as my say,
Pedro, uh, on,
he breaks up all the figurines
and after the episode, uh,
Don Quixote has to pay for
each one of those figurines,
each one of those characters,
depending on the importance
of the character in the story.
So you can see that it is a satire
of the value of literary inventure.
Uh, it is a Yvan Fleming
said, you know, my,
my James Bond is worth so
much on the Pussy Galore.
This woman who appears in one
of his movies had Rachel's
Lee named Pussy Galore.
Uh, is, uh, is, uh, is worth so
much and so forth and, and, and,
and,
and so on.
No.
So
the, uh, um, the second part was, uh,
was written in a hurry.
And let me,
let me show you in how much of a hurry
in detail by quoting one Henry Sullivan
who, uh, uh, in a, in a book
called a grotesque purgatory,
uh, writes the following, and I'm
quoting and follow this closely.
He says,
part two of the key hot,
they was begun in 16,
12,
seven years after her on the stocks
and well on its way by July 16,
13,
about halfway about half complete by 20.
July 16,
14.
Then continued at
breakneck speed in fall 16,
14.
And finally completed by
January or February 16,
15,
a period of about two and a
half years in all unquote,
I will get returned to this, uh, uh,
by using a quote from Manuel do
wrong, but you can see the, uh,
how does a solid one know
this board from evidence,
from documents and
statements do. I said, well,
there's another sense of worth
about how the novel was developed.
You will see that part too is it's quite,
quite long.
No,
one of the best critics
of our millionaire does,
uh, the whole thing was stiffen Gilman,
who was for many years a
professor at Harvard. And, uh,
he, um, he, he wrote an essay
called the Apocrypha lucky hot.
They're very much are worth
reading, uh, uh, in which he,
he has, uh, a memorable phrase. Uh,
Gilman says that's advantage rather than
confront our DNA that when she does to
a certain extent,
court prefers to encompass
him in a web of irony,
he says, said, avant this through a
net of irony, a web of irony over, uh,
his rival. You will see how he does
that because actually I'm a Anita.
His greatest triumph,
his book didn't have much success,
was to wind up as a character.
We think don Quixote is fiction and
having his characters incorporated into
Tulum,
keyholders fiction to add to the game
of mirrors that Quixote already was
in fact a critic.
Uh,
and with enough time in their hands,
critics and scholars will
almost say anything. Uh,
a critic claimed in fixed in in 1915 that,
uh,
the Apocrypha that the hotel had
been written by Cervantes himself.
Um, that's absurd. But, uh,
at some level, uh, it makes sense
because it's Arianna hadn't existed.
Cervantes would have had to invent him
in the way that he uses him in part two
of the Quixote.
Now if you want to read
the most outlandish, uh,
take on all this,
you must read a story by the
Argentine master Jorge Luis Borges,
who wrote a story called Pierre Menard,
author of the Quixote
in which, uh, a French,
uh,
poet minors color and so forth,
decides to write the Quixote again,
but not a different Quixote,
but the same key hot they word for
word as sort of aunties had written it.
A,
it is a,
is a dizzying theoretical meditation on
all of these Games of authorship that
Cervantes initiates himself in part one
of the Quixote and continues in part two
in a sense,
the appearance of our [inaudible].
It's like a self fulfilling prophecy.
If there was a CD, I met a bidding,
Haley,
who was supposed to have been the real
author of the Quixote and is of course,
a fictional author.
Suddenly Cervantes finds himself with
a real false author of the Quixote.
So this is what the other
[inaudible] book adds to the Quixote.
Now, the [inaudible] book,
uh, is tremendously boring.
Uh, it is conceived within
scholastic philosophy. Uh,
the characters instead
of engaging in dialogue,
have long monologues
that are, uh, really, uh,
obnoxious, uh, uh, Don Quixote
is not in love with. We'll see.
There he is the,
uh,
the loving night sanctuary
is a bit pornographic.
Uh, and, uh, uh, it is,
uh, in fact, uh, uh,
a very dull a book that only those of us
who are a set of and testers and cannot
avoid doing. So, uh, read, um,
so, so much about our
[inaudible]. Uh, and now,
uh, let's move on to part
two. Uh, you have a treat,
uh, in store it because in my view, part
two is better than part one if that,
if that is possible, although scholars
argue back and forth about this. But I,
I think that there is no,
no question.
Part two is a superior a book and is even
much more complicated and complicated
by the fact that characters in part to
have read part one adding to the game of
mirrors.
And you will find this in the
very early chapters of part two.
I'm going to read you now a few quotes
again from Durang's set Avantis the uh,
because they serve as a good uh,
uh, introduction, uh,
to part two because it is
kind of a synthesis of,
of what [inaudible] thinks or thought
about the Quixote at this point.
And you have some general ideas
before embarking on reading the uh,
part two of the hotel.
These are quotes,
he says the art of dialogue in Servantez
reaches its peak in the second half of
his novel. It is true. Second part,
there is much more dialogue and not
just between sanctuary. Don Quixote,
those dialogues. And we enjoy so much
and they're more here, but among many,
uh, different characters with
different points of view, different,
different ways of speaking
and, and, and so forth. Again,
drunk.
It is also in the second part when the
interaction of the two main characters,
the night and his choir reaches a climax,
central Pansa becomes increasingly quick.
So ticed and even a certain moments
occupies the center of the stage.
Having become temporarily
the novels center character,
there is an impressive trick.
It is not done with mirrors.
It is achieved through dialogue on quote,
and this is true.
You will see that sanctuary in various
chapters that I'm not going to anticipate
and ruin for you becomes the
protagonist of the novel. Uh,
and there is a back and forth between,
uh, Don Quixote and sanctuary.
Okay.
Again,
[inaudible] human memory,
the memory of the squire and his
master ruminates upon the past,
nothing that occurs in their
travels is entirely finished.
They will talk about what has happened
to them and try to find a meaning to
every obscure detail
etched in their memory.
Every possibility the future holds open
will influence their present attitudes
since the past.
Keep on echoing upon the present and the
future keeps on working its magic upon
the minds of the two characters.
Each moment of the present is made richer
and more subtle by the interplay of
past,
present and future of quote to this,
I might add that the presence
of part one as a memory,
uh, is, uh,
an important one in part two and uh,
a device, uh, of part two, uh,
is that many episodes are in some way
a rewriting of episodes of part one and
rewriting that is usually much
more complicated and elaborate.
But you can see the kernel of the episode
from part one in the episode in part
two. This has to do this,
this racist of course,
philosophical issues about
memory and about, uh,
about the repetition of the past and all
of that that we will be talking about
when we reached those episodes.
Okay.
The interaction between the individual
and his environment is shown to be unique.
It escapes logic and language because
logic and language are systems of labels
super imposed upon our experience.
And Cervantes wants to free us from
all labels by showing how much each
individual is capable of interpreting
his own facet of a multifaceted reality.
Yeah. The, the, the, the,
the presence of reality
in its multifaceted ways.
And there were even interpreting becomes
much more complicated in part too
because this guy says proliferate and uh,
uh,
a lot more of the action takes place,
not in the open air but indoors where,
uh,
where, uh, charades can be
organized and, and, and so forth.
Yeah.
Now the following quote, which is, uh, uh,
a little long but takes us back to the
composition of part two and I think
we'll, I hope round out your cause, your,
your knowledge of it as you,
as you, uh, approach, uh,
reading it [inaudible] goes,
the sense of unreality is
heightened throughout part two.
When Don Quixote on Santo
have to face their doubles,
their reflection in the mirror,
they meet people who have read part
one or five or have heard about it.
They have to react to what this readers
of their previous adventures think about
them.
Even worse after chapter 36 we just
wouldn't say Advantis finds out about the
existence of Avaya Neda's book after
chapter 36 they have to fight off another
image of themselves.
The Bogles image in the crooked mirror
of Avaya Neda's fake second part,
the false Kihatha doors.
The end of 1614 Cervantes was
working is what we went over,
but now I'm going to repeat
it in a different key.
Cervantes was working on
chapter 36 [inaudible] second
part are we gonna do this
book appeared in October of the same year.
Cervantes reacted by writing
38 chapters in seven months,
uh,
strenuous effort,
which may have exhausted what
was left over precarious health.
This bureau,
second part was the work of an unknown
author of a young Nigga is obviously a
pseudonym, is a pen name. We
don't know who really have a,
I was boats Advantis hard.
One reputation was in danger until he
could refute the piracy by issuing his own
part too.
He was also indignant at the lack of
intelligence and sensitivity of his
imitator. He wasn't even a bad imitator.
If he had been a good imitator,
he may have been flattered.
He's anger is expressed
through his main characters.
Don Quixote on Santo have
to face your ugly ghosts.
They must convince the readers of Ypn,
NATO's book that day are real characters
are intruders trying to usurp their
personality, their selves, their reality.
It is a situation only Cervantes
or Pirandello could have device.
The illusion here is doing when she
Pirandello a great Italian play,
right of the 20th century who wrote
a famous play calls six characters in
search. Oh offer. So this,
this Cervantes characters
are the other characters,
Blair reality or functionality in a way,
having read part one yourselves,
you are like some of the characters in
part two of the hotel and you are in the
very, in a very similar situation
as you go through that second part.
Okay,
we'll leave it there.